hello everyone and welcome to a game I
mentioned that I will show in the
previous video it's a Gary Casper with
the white pieces against my nephew field
Marty and the game took place during the
rest day of the Croatian Grantchester
Gary Kasparov and Maurice Ashley wants
to expand its and Croatia to open the
the chess beach it's quite famous there
forever in Croatia and through phoenix'
do do with the chess Beach free you know
you will have a very nice time and
during well during that day there was a
junior tournament and I think it's years
the 11 through 16
so whoever won the the top place in
their own division got a chance to play
at the simultaneous exhibition against
former world champion Garry Kasparov I
feel it won first place in his own
division and thus he was granted the
chance to play play the former champion
and this is the game were showing which
is very interesting I don't know those
of you who have been subscribed to the
channel a bit longer last year his
father got a mark teach my
brother-in-law face to garlic as part of
and well it was also a very nice game if
you haven't seen a do check it out it
will be the first link you will see in
the description below so you know if you
check out both games then you will be
able to decide who fared better against
Gary for father or son so without
further ado let's just check out this
nice photo that we have there we have it
casparo
over the board and Phillip of course
waiting for Caspar to make his move so
let's check out the game cuz para with
the white pieces opens with E for
Phillip always plays the Sicilian
against force so we have C 592 f3 and g6
Phillip goes for the hyperaccelerated
dragon which is always very nice if
you're if you don't feel up to learning
like millions of lines of all the
different lines of the Sicilian then you
can learn the hyperaccelerated dragon
and white ball and we have a few choices
how to how to tackle the
hyperaccelerated dragon because part of
decides to tackle the dragon with c3p
prepares d4 doesn't go for the media to
d4 which is the main line with Bishop to
g7 by Philip and now only d4 by Kasparov
now we'll see capture some d4c captures
and now d5 this is the strongest move
and also the main line so Phil place it
with
five and now push up the g4 and here
casparo goes for night beat the two
defends the night and there it's been
known to play in the top level chess
Vasili when shook played it I in 2015
against a Christian troika in the petrov
memorial and he wouldn't want a very
nice game with here Knight B to d2 is
usually met with Knight to c6 as the
knight here is spin so nice it comes
with a threat of knife capture son
before this is the main line but Phillip
goes for a six and it's been played only
once before but e six was met with Queen
to b3 as the bishop is now on g4 Queen
to b3 is a known move where the b7 point
is under attack but here Kasper goes for
Bishop to b5 check and now it is already
as a move eight that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens here the black king is in check
you have to defend it
Filip defended by developing a piece
with Knight to d7 and now h3 and Gary
asks what do you want to do with the
bishop obviously if we go h5 or a5g4 is
coming so you basically have to capture
on f3 width but some characters on f3
and now you have to be careful if Gary
does something silly like knife
characters here then of course Queen to
a5 check wins the bishop on b5 so first
Gary just trades on the 7 with special
characters Queen captures and now Knight
captures on f3 Phillip continues
developing with nice to e7 and here with
castles castles by black as well and now
Bishop to f4 usually you know the the
most basic chess principle will tell you
that you want to develop your piece as
far as deep into the opponent's position
as you're allowed but here at Casper's
plan is to go Queen's the d2 and go
Bishop to Bishop h6 the trade of the
darks for bishops so in this case it
doesn't really matter with Knights the
c6 by Phillip and now comes Queen to d2
and here Phillip doesn't just want to
wait for Kasparov to do whatever he
likes
well the show page 6 is of course coming
so he decides to strike in the center we
have f6 and now we always have to ask
ourselves if it's okay to play f6 if
it's okay to play of vi the counter
White's strong center then you should
always play it if it's not okay then
well you you should never play it here
it's a it's really a double digit idea
because of course you do want to get rid
of white strong center it's a very
nicely advanced ee5 form but on the
other hand by playing f6 you're
weakening your East exponent so this
will not remain a target pretty much for
the rest of the game with rook F 2 e 1
by Kasparov defending as d5 pawn was now
attacked three times and Phillip trades
in the center we have pawn captures with
Knight captures on e5 Knight captures on
e5 captures on e5 and now just a6
preparing to play b5 you can go rook the
c8 maybe even roof to c4 and bring the
other rook over to see it there are a
lot of ideas here for black but it all
depends on what whitey does
Bishop captures and g7 by Kasparov with
King Capra's on g7 and now like we said
as Casper has a pawn on d4 II six is a
weak backwards punk-ass borrow now is
ready to attack it so first he wants the
double rooks on the e-file rookie three
Kasparov prepares rook a to e1 and now
there are different ways you can defend
a d6 pawn for example you could try
something like rook 88 bring this rook
over to e7 bring the other rook over to
8 but you will never be able to push a 5
so placing your rooks on 8 + e 7 could
be it could be somewhat passive so
Phillip decides to go for a more active
plan with b5 by black and now rook a to
e1 just challenging these spawn and now
rook to f6
so here Phillip still has the option of
well if needed this rook can come t8 but
then again he has the same I open a file
so rook to f8 is also an idea as the f2
phone could become a target of attack
but now Kasparov transfers the game over
to the only open file on the board that
is the C file we have rook to c3 with
ideas of supporting the rook for example
and then the roof to c7 would win the
game as you would lose the Queen
so rook the c8 by Phillip and now rook
captures on c8 with Queen captures on C
it and sorry Queen captures on c8 and
now White Queen to c7 Queen captures on
c8 and now rook the c1 attacking the
Queen and also once again winning the C
file as for the moment this rook is
stuck on f6 you can't really bring it
back into the game so Queens the b8 I
feel like we gets the Queen out of the
way and also as he's targeting the e5
square he has ideas of pushing a 5
but also Queen to f4 is a possibility
where he would if he is able to force a
queen trade here it would be hard for
white to push a win in this position
where the material on the board is equal
black doesn't really have any weaknesses
okay the the backwards e sucks pawn is
weak but with only one rook on the board
it will be hard for example if the
Queen's get traded off even if you get
rook c6 and white can just play
something like e 5 and it will it could
you know work out well for black but
here
a sparrow goes g3 he takes away the f4
square from the black Queen and now
comes C 5 by Phillip and here it took as
part of some time to decide what to do
here as it always is in the simultaneous
exhibition as part of you know strolls
around you know visits every player and
then after Caspar gets to your board you
have to make your move and then Kasparov
looks at the board and then he decides
what to play so here he took some time
and here he decided to go for Queen to
c3 he should have gone for just captures
on e5 and after Queen captures rook the
c5 with an attack against the d5 pawn
here as it's really really difficult to
defend this pawn for example if you go
look to d6 black is lost just rooks e7
check you can't block the check you can
go to h6 for example King to f6 and now
Queen to h6 will will be sufficient for
a win but okay Caspar went Queen to c3
and now Phillip just advanced the pawn
with E 4 and here although you can now
trade the Queen's here we have Queen to
c7 check by Kasparov Queen captures on
c7 rook captures with check rook to f7
of course Casper not interested in
trading rooks here we have rook to c5
and now what do you do here it's really
hard to defend your d5 point for example
if you go here then white will just
transfer the attention over to the other
Queens iPhones we have rook to c6 you
attack the pawn and now after you
advance it you just go back rook c5 and
now you either lose this point or if the
rook defends you will lose this point or
if you push then you will even lose the
a 5 points so not not an option
defending this pawn would rook to these
seven on the other hand if rook f5
you can go h4 and then when this pawn
advances the the g4 you will once again
I have to move your roof again not
something you want to do plus it's a
very passive idea to just defend your
phone from f5 so here Phillip finds a
very nice active move he plays III of
course now the idea is if you capture
here then pawn captures an f2 comes with
check which of course Kasparov does not
allow he plays F captures on e3 but now
there are weaknesses in his position all
of a sudden Caspar has three pawn
islands and now Phillip attacks it with
rook to f3 targeting the g3 pawn which
will come with check targeting the e3
pawn and Kasparov decides to capture on
d5 we look at for Sun d5 rook captures
and g3 with check King to f2 and now
rook captures on h3 so the material on
the board is once again equal but now
you get this position where Kasparov has
he played before in this position
because portal now has two connected
passed pawns in the center whereas
Phillip has two connected passed pawns
on the side of the board and white is to
be preferred here as White's pawns are
well much more advanced than black spots
which means they are closer to the to
the queening Square but also as in every
endgame you know the advantage has the
better player and the one who studied
the endgame or which is why I always say
you have to study the endgame
so here Phillip continues rook to H to
check with King to e3 and now you don't
want to you know grab needless material
for example if you capture then Ruby 7
check and after the King moves for
example if you want to keep an eye on
you on your pony five is coming and you
can start pushing your pawns here the
King is just in the way and the white is
just much better here
so here Phillip not being greedy he
decides to push his own past bone as
well we have h5 and Kasparov of course
continues pushing in the center we have
a 5 this is now the theme of the game
passed pawns must be pushed so what do
you do here here I felt decided it was
important to keep pushing his past pawns
but in this case even though you should
always push your past pawns you
shouldn't push your passport here here
Phil played h4 but h4 is not not the
best move here here you should have gone
for rope to h3 check and to just keep
Kasparov sking at bay
for example King f4 you're gonna go rook
the h4 check and now of course you can't
go
deeper into the position with King g5
because ruby g4 is mate
you would have to go back for example
rook King to g3 but then you get the g5
and now the White King is completely
caught off from from entering the
position and now the black King can help
out with the defense against the two
connected passed pawns in the center so
this is what black should have gone here
but okay Phillip continues pushing the
past pawn we have h4 but now it Ruby d7
check by Kasparov now you cannot go to
f6 as the pawn is guarding that square
with King to f8 and here again cuz part
of took to his time we even have a video
of this position was a a Philips father
took the video so here it is we're just
gonna check it out for a very short time
there you have it
seconds the video is some few minutes
long but he didn't start recording as
prob is analyzing and I'm not sure about
all this too too hard too high so let's
just lower that for a minute
this is how much time Kasparov is is
taking in this position let's just move
that over here maybe you can see the
board better but now you can't but it's
not it's not an easy decision on what to
do in this position so there we have it
as part of really trying to figure out
what to do here just so you see what an
intense position it is so even though
Prospero who started the end game you
know relentlessly him of course he still
has to calculate all the variants so
there Harris Phillip has a nice sip of
his water a very intense position and
it's really hot outside so you have to
take that into consideration as well
there you have it
well as long as we're watching it we're
just gonna wait for him to make a move
really really intense have it but you
know such a young fellow like Phillips
facing with the legendary Kasparov or
not not all that nervousness you know
one would expect him to be more nervous
you know there is some footwork going on
there and some plane which with the
pawns but it's not nothing nothing too
much it's part of calculating in he said
you know some blindfold endgame
calculation going on there still still
haven't decided what what to play
because you know it's an end game you
have to calculate it all the way all the
way to the end really really intense and
there you have it because part of me the
move d5 is on the board so as you've
seen
casparo plays d5 here and now Phillip
continues pushing his own passport with
h3 here and now Kasparov pushes d6 and
now it's uh you know it's already a very
dangerous position the point is that the
d6 for example there are some ideas like
you even made threats for example e six
rooked h7 followed by rook to H it will
well not be made but if the King goes to
the center of the board already some
ideas are lurking in there
so here what do you do if you go rook
capture some b2 then rook to h7 like we
said very strong you have a rogue behind
a passed pawn so obviously we're not
cleaning at the D 78 is coming as far as
King is placed in such a beautiful
square so you cannot defend the pawns
from behind so after these six we have
King - eh by Phillip but this only helps
Kasparov we have grouped to h7 now II 6
and rook to H it definitely is the
threat of checkmate because the pawns
will be guarding all of the all of the
squares in front of the black king and
now rook to h1 by Phillip trying to get
Kasparov to play east 6 so he can get in
from behind rook t1 check and pick up
the pawn which would of course be a big
mistake for Kasparov Casper ghost came
to f2 he doesn't allow rook to e1 and
I'm rook H to check with King to f3 and
now look to h1 but now it's not all that
problematic for white
so Kasparov just pushes East six now
raakhi one is nothing because rook to h8
is checkmate
so King to f8 field prevents mate but
now these seven is coming so of course
you have to prevent d8 checkmate we have
rook to d1 by Phillip and here Kasparov
just pushes East seven with Czech we
have King to g8 and now there are a lot
of winning ideas here for white Kasparov
chooses the the most obvious one rook
captures on h3 and it was in this
position that Phil acknowledged resigned
the game as there is nothing more to do
here whatever you do if you capture this
point and this point Queens and well
you're just lost and any other move that
well that white black does will of
course result in in in quick quick
checkmate so but this is what it means
you know look at those very nice pawns
on b7 and e7 passports must be pushed
except you know when when they shouldn't
like in the case where I one felt pushed
h4 and there was a better sequence but
this is what I why I always say you
should always study the endgame and I
recommend that Phillip that he should
take up what his endgame manual and
really study study the hell out of that
book and you know maybe next time when
he faces part of he will he will be able
to play a much better endgame
because even though this was a lot of a
lot of moments this endgame was a drone
and game so to say but having drawn
position and being able to hold a drone
position against Garry Kasparov are two
very different things
as you saw in this game so also we have
a very nice video footage by by Goran
Marty she's foreign
is foreseen
and also casparo was so impressed with
this game that after the game finished
he even did a quick analysis of the game
so we can check that out as well let's
that feeling bro bro what are you mr.
Kasparov natural out but you can see
yeah and it's lagging a bit but sorry
it's just my PC I don't really have a
very strong PC
well yeah you can see that the sparrow
was also very very impressed with the
game
yours their habits the final handshake
and what are you what a game bye-bye
Martic against the former world champion
Garry Kasparov now like I said to check
out the game his father played against
the Garry Kasparov it will be the first
link in the description below so you can
decide for yourselves who played the
better game father or son and you know
it's also also a very nice game but yeah
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it you know always remember
study the endgame I would like to thank
mikaël Bogart for introduced to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the creation Grantchester is
checking up in your suggestions and so
on and so on
thank you all I will see you soon have
an excellent rest of your Sunday